people are under the impression that the
internet is sort of anonymous by default
they don't know how many digital trails
are leaving behind I am Nick let's me
with reason TV and today we're talking
with Karen Riley she heads up the Tor
project Karen thanks for talking with us
tor bills itself as an online anonymity
tool that allows you to browse the
Internet interact online without being
traceable tell us a little bit about how
tor works
so what tor does is it bounces your
communications through three relays that
are randomly selected from a volunteer
network of about 3000 in 90 countries so
you can download the tor browser bundle
for free and then you connect to this
volunteer network randomly select your
three relays it connects to it and it
then a version of Firefox that's
configured to protect you against all
sorts of other attacks from plugins and
other malicious software bounces up and
then you are free to browse freely talk
about how the idea for the Tor project
came about what are its roots and what
do you hope to achieve tor actually
began as a project of the Naval Research
Laboratory the idea behind it for a
military application is that if your
adversary can tell where your
communication hub is whether it's a
person who talks to everybody whether
it's a ship whether it's an installation
somewhere then they can disrupt your
entire operation by going after that
target so tor separates the origin and
the destination of your communication
how about how many people do you have
any sense of how many people you have
voluntary thousand volunteers and ninety
countries how many users do you have or
do you keep track of that we have a
project about measuring anonymous
networks without giving up end-user
information so with this we're able to
tell that we have about half a million
daily users what are some of the reasons
why typical Americans might want to use
tor
well we've asked we don't give up their
information unless someone actually says
yes tell my story because tor exists to
give you a choice about how much
information
you give up now we talked to people who
just think that widespread surveillance
is creepy they have a medical condition
that they don't want their Internet
service provider to know about because
that information isn't covered under
HIPAA or maybe it's someone in a rural
area where there is P is one one person
and that person abuses their position of
power to know what everybody in their
community is doing we also talk to
victims of violence who need to to reach
out to their peers in order to get
support but sometimes going through
horrible things carries a stigma and you
shouldn't have no access to a support
network just because people are jerks
who don't have empathy there's a lot of
everyday reasons why people would use
tor you don't necessarily have to be
somebody who's under a particular threat
to want privacy are people waking up to
the idea that the Internet is not
possibly as anonymous or as private as
they once thought people are under the
impression that the Internet is sort of
anonymous by default they don't know how
many digital trails are leaving behind
so these are things that we've known to
be technically possible but a lot of
people react to us as if we have tinfoil
hats on and say well I'm not important
why would anybody why would anybody be
tracking what I do and this includes a
lot of activists who tend to be really
really humble so I'm not really a target
I'm not that important Barack Obama came
into office promising the most
transparent administration ever he kind
of he doesn't seem to be particularly
internet savvy but he kind of positions
himself as a forward guy who has an iPod
you know this type of stuff is a
particularly useful that you know people
recognize that this happens under George
Bush and it happens under Barack Obama
well restricting power isn't a matter of
whether you like this administration or
or this one it's about restricting power
because that person that you trust with
that power is not always going to be the
president tour is not you would not say
tour is in the service of a particular
idiot
it's more of a technology could you
explain that a little bit so we're not a
democracy promotion tool we're not for
any particular group of people we exist
to give ordinary people control over
their information we exist to to sort of
restore the balance of power between the
powerless and the powerful to be able to
speak truth to power but if you want to
reform one type of system or abolish it
altogether
that's not our choice to make we exist
for freedom of expression and privacy
does the US government which I mean you
know this comes out of the Navy it gets
government support are they okay with
that or has that been tested yet because
there are plenty of times in the past
where the US government has said you
know what freedom of expression right up
into the moment you know right up to the
moment that we don't want freedom of
expression well any government is not
some sort of monolithic hive mind there
there are people that are perfectly okay
with tor existing and then there were
some that believe that freedom on the
Internet is a great threat but we have
answers for all of them at least in a
free society there is a balance between
freedom for everybody and freedom for
the people that you may not like is it
that you know that the playing field is
just going to be you know constantly
leveled as governments get you know more
powerful and then the hackers come back
and level it again I think it requires
constant vigilance and it's not a matter
of technology alone it's about
technology and policy and some
technologies they can't complete these
circumvent governments that it's just
not within the power of the hackers of
the world to do that but what we can do
is empower people who are reaching out
to the general public and and letting
them know what is happening and urging
them to go through legal means by
political means to cut down on this
technology and part of that is letting
people know what's happening you can't
object to something that you don't know
happening so that's why we work with
activists and journalists who are
shining a light on these corrupt and
dangerous practices well I think we'll
leave it there I want to thank Karen
Riley of the Tor project for talking
with recent TV I'm Nick Gillespie thanks
thank you